Christian Bale reveals what he really  thinks about Ben Affleck as Batman  aw dang Detroit is looking bright before  Ben Affleck was cast as Batman Christian  Bale was the one saving Gotham City  he caught up with the actor on Tuesday  in LA where he not only praised his  Batman successor but also the film  itself everyone brings their own they  don't do that as well I think the  trailers are looking bright I'm looking  forward to that but not everyone shares  bales enthusiasm here's what his co-star  Morgan Freeman told ET last week I  haven't happy for Ben because the Dark  Knight was almost it pretty much it  did you see Batman Begins yes I don't  think you can beat that still though  Bale appreciated Freeman's kind words  right on for Morgan for saying no one  will ever be there I very much liked it  you